[Musique]
j'appelle à haute
roland
devant fondation de dates en tant que
client
[Applaudissements]
trois points c'est un ancien guerrier
qui était fidèle courageux et cependant
les chinois qui voyagent
ce rendement la protection de cet
empereur la haie à côté ce sont des son
fils et le son à charlotte de corps
[Applaudissements]
depuis des années je fréquente le temps
panier
au début c'était ma parents qui m'ont
que j'accompagnais mes parents ensuite
je suis devenu membre du bureau de
l'association depuis 83
on l'a formé un conseil d administration
du bureau et on m'a nommé comme
fonctions de trésorier général
j'ai assumé cette fonction pendant
25 ans est bien une association chez
chat ça permet de regrouper les amis et
les parents de la communauté chinoise un
lieu de rencontre un lieu de prière
oui
[Musique]
c'est bien parce que il ya une culture
ancestrale là et il faut sauvegarder
cette culture le cumul proprement dite
et les activités culturelles
pour cela le la vocation de gandhi c'est
de sauvegarder sa culture d'une façon on
peut avoir la culture française et
culture chinoise
[Musique]
signalons ce n'est qu'en 28